hey i'm john patrick shanley the writer
and director of
wild mountain time and today i'm talking
with emily blunt and jamie dornan
about a sort of big set piece
towards the end of the film which takes
place
in a rosemary muldoon's kitchen and
rosemary muldoon
is played by emily blunt uh so
basically just to remind you i know
you've seen the film
uh or at least that's what i was told uh
the
uh jamie's trapped outside uh
in a violent rainstorm uh and
emily's not answering the door and he's
doused with the giant
a draft of brain that comes down just
about drowns and then she lets him in
and the dog gets in a little bit later
and they go in the kitchen and they sit
down
and walk around and they talk for a heck
of a long time
and so uh we thought we might just you
know
uh batted about a little bit about what
it's like to do
a set piece like that uh in a film
uh where usually the scenes are much
shorter
and so i guess i'd like to start by uh
asking
emily uh how do you prepare
when you know you're going to be doing
an extended sequence like that
um i think first of all i start
you know i just read it and read it and
read it and read it over and over again
until i
feel that by osmosis just absorbing it
all i have a sort of concept of what
really what the architecture of it is
going to be more than anything
because you do want that shape to it so
that it's not
and then eventually it'll rise to a
climax and then it will all sort of come
out in the wash
so how do you pace it what do you reveal
when and what is each moment really
about so that
i always felt that kitchen scene was
almost overwhelming at first to
look at because i knew it was just
monstrously long
you know even though most theatrics
would be like come on get on with it you
know
but i think we're not used to that in
film and
um it just excited me so much you know
that we would get to live
in in the world of one scene for about
20 minutes
that of the of the film and we shot it
over
five days and i was aware of that when i
spoke to you in sort of prepping it we
were gonna just
shoot it and shoot it and shoot it until
the whole thing was done
and i think that was really thrilling to
me as well
that i just wanted to make sure that the
shape of it was in line with what
you saw when you wrote it
and i wanted it to be
this sort of battle between them
and it's her final you know thanksgiving
from my perspective going into that
scene
this is rosemary's this is the
climax of her plight in like trying to
get anthony to fall in love with her
be with her and make the right decision
finally in in in
in his life she is at her wits end so
there's a sort of
passionate desperation to her at the top
of this
um and she has him trapped and
and even how you wrote it in the script
i was like oh it's a very
tiny little kitchen it's like she's got
him cornered
and what does that look like and what
would that feel like so that's sort of
the kind of things i thought about and
then i thought i've got to learn these
bloody
lines you know there's rather a lot of
them
and then your uh your quarry uh
uh jamie uh
he so you're the hunted one in this
scene
and i loosened you up by
dumping a barrel of freezing cold water
over your head right before you come
into the house
which i remember you really appreciated
uh and uh
then you find yourself in that and so
what was it like for you
to prepare for and do this scene
let's not forget that you know uh before
every take
um i'm getting re-grade with water to
make sure that i'm sufficiently wet
um to pick on the scene which
uh i'm gonna you know gonna say that's
it was a harder deal for me
because emily at least got to do it dry
um i i've got the worst
end of the stick there but you know i
feel like a scene like that a big set
piece like that where
in this movie every
everything is being said that scene you
know everything that he's
always wanted to say but couldn't say
but then it's forced into saying because
he's sort of trapped and she's
manipulating him into this point where
he has to get it out as uncomfortable as
that is for him it's all happening in
that scene
so you know there's so much writing on
it i feel like a scene like that you
always um well i always i like
you know the actors are the last people
to get schedules and it
really really frustrates me um and i
know
a million reasons why producers don't
like actors of schedules but
i i get very panicky about learning
lines and i'm particularly a big scene
like that where there's
so much that i like to sort of plan it
like i'm not very good at it and i'd
like to make sure i have the right time
and have a process to learn lines and
uh when i get a schedule and i know
there's a scene like that i i that's the
one
i like and everything sort of works
towards that i'm always like oh my god
right okay i've got
11 days until that big scene you know
and luckily as emily said we had a few
days with
the kitchen scene so that was great you
know um but it's the one you're most
fearful of
because um it doesn't work unless that
scene works you know
and definitely it was the scene that
emily and i
we had a chance to get together and and
you know and rehearse
um when we could it was always straight
to that scene you know it's not
we weren't mucking about any other it
was like rightness
let's do the kitchen scene we got it
over
and over and over and over and over
again until it's in our heads
um but in saying that as often as the
case with these things
um the most fun scene to shoot you know
and it's just so rewarding you know your
beautiful words and
and by that stage i think emily and i
had such a strong sort of sense of these
crazy people and it was just you know it
was just
it was a dance you know it was it was a
dance and the movement
of it and the emotion of it and being
able
to sort of really truly
react in a way that i knew how emily was
going to move his rosemary and i felt i
knew how i was going to move as anthony
and that was felt
never stronger than in in that kitchen
scene so
it was a joy to shoot it i mean i i was
on such a high when we finished on that
friday i remember
very clearly because i drove down um
south to connemara a couple of hours
just seeing my family on that friday
like
and i kind of wept
[Laughter]
really crazy emotional and um i felt
like there was this sort of exodus of
anthony as i drove through
maybe and
so yeah it was it definitely had an
effect on me that that scene
you know i've had a lifelong
desire for some ill-defined
thing which revolves around conversation
i've always had an ache in my chest
to have a certain conversation with
somebody
and i knew that if i could have this
conversation
my life would finally make sense be
solved
and that i would open a door into a
bigger room
uh and uh it's one of the big reasons
that i write
and this scene
is that conversation for me
uh and uh you know i always sort of
notice how i feel and so uh
you know many mornings i got up as as we
all did
in darkness in ireland and it's raining
and it's cold uh and i think
you know where am i and what am i doing
today
and that morning i woke up in the dark
and i thought i what i'm having this
feeling i've
i'm having a feeling that i've had
before
when did i feel this way before and i
thought
when i was a child on christmas morning
uh and i walked in that day knowing
both of you were incredibly well
prepared
very frightened uh and
that that would only make you both that
much the better
you know there's a i've had a couple of
rounds of eye surgery
and they give you like a pamphlet and
one of the things it says
in the pamphlet is with eye surgery
a little fear is good
and that's also true of acting i think
uh uh that you know you walk in and
you're in a heightened state and it's
funny you know with all the anxiety
about lines and everything
neither one of you had one word wrong
ever in that scene in all of that scene
uh uh i mean you know you had the
occasional flub or whatever but
you were absolutely pristine
in that regard and i could see that you
had entered
a certain kind of metaphysical meadow
where everything was kind of working
for you supporting you you know like the
sun came out for a minute and the
clouds cleared and all of the problems
of
your challenges that both of you endure
as human beings on this earth for a
moment disappeared
and you were finally free and free to do
that thing that you love
more than anything else forgive me
presuming to say that uh
and uh and that it was long enough
for you to luxuriate in it that it
wasn't oh you know you didn't just get
to have this great moment and then it
was out
you could stay there
and i wanted to stay there i mean i like
the way you say that like luxuriate in
it because you know like it's sort of
the opposite to
the the big climactic rain scene which
is so
like you've been thrown into a fire
and you're uh you know in a straight
jacket and you've got a minute to get
out of it
once you know it felt like you know and
it's mad and it's a real
thrill and a rush and you come out of it
go oh my god what happened in there was
it good i don't know
you're looking uh for reactions to sort
of show you the way
and inform you how it is whereas
something like that we got to
you know soak it all up and soak it in
and
and and sort of wallow in this sort of
heaviness of it and also the lightness
of it and the beauty of it and the
darkness of it
all of the mad layers written in that
kitchen scene
and it it did feel in the nicest way
like sort of indulgent
you know that we were able to shoot it
over a couple of days and really
you know make it right and i i'm really
proud of that scene you know i think
it's like you know
i i i you know it's great and it was
yeah as i said before so fun to shoot
you were sort of encouraging me to use
every prop as a device to woo him and so
even the candle
was put in front of me and you said now
move it towards him
and even that just slowly moving it
towards him like it was so
exquisite because and because
jamie is anthony by that point like he
knows what she's doing and she's kind of
like lethal
like moving in for the kill here so even
like moving a candle across he was like
oh my god like come on stop it stop it
even something like that so i think that
was the
boiling pot was having it all in this
small confined space where no one can
escape and so
every single moment nuance touch
move closer is magnified and it felt
magnified
on the day like everything mattered
everything had a reason
and it was all this desperate pursuit
and she you're right she was hunting him
down and
and like we've talked about before you
know and like it's a line in the film
where you talk about the irish not being
very direct people
she is like thrown caution to the women
everything that's in her dna as an irish
person is gone and she is
having that conversation that you were
talking about
and his own discomfort is not only
because it's his personality but it's in
his dna as an irish
person that you do not talk about this
stuff
if you don't ask me those questions you
know so the whole thing and jamie is
irish so it's sort of in
his bloodstream that whole thing you
know and it was just
it was just heaven and i totally get why
you cried jamie because i think
it's very true when you get to do a
scene like that you are
free and it's hard to explain it to
people until john patrick shanley
explains it
to us you know how it makes you feel and
it did feel exactly like you said you're
sort of flying suddenly and it's very
special
when you're having fun at work and my
whole mo with this you know life choice
to
be an actor is to have fun with it and
and
make sure that no matter how dark the
materials are moving
you're having fun at work because why
would you pick such a crazy
career path um if not to have to have
fun
and explore um all these different
aspects of your own being
um i think the best days and and the
best scenes are
you feel that you just do them all day
you do them again you know and if and
actually there's a part of you if um
you know the ad your mom said jesus i
don't know how to tell you this but
they didn't have any any film in the
camera
we're gonna have to do it again tomorrow
and you'd be like
oh what yeah right yeah no and i doubt
you know that felt like that to me i
could have done it all again and again i
loved it
now you had this extra thing which was
you had a secret and she wants to know
what the secret
is and it's a very it was a very
unusual secret and the people who watch
this
know what the secret is so you're
walking around
with this secret this revelation that
she's trying to get out of you and
you don't want to give up and what was
that like
it's the most painful thing ever to let
that go like truly
felt like um
like the delicacy that it would take to
sort of genuinely
harness and harbor and look after a bee
um throughout that entire scene
and then eventually the sort of pained
relief
to actually just give it a tiny wee hole
that it can make and just like get out
and survive
and it felt like that you know i felt
like um
this other like um
like like pain like it was painful to
release it but then once i
released it it was um joy
you know and uh you know i've said this
before you know it doesn't happen very
often as an actor like
i had convinced myself by the time that
we got
to that that very moment
where i say i believe that i am a honey
bee
i believe that i as me as jamie gornan
believed that i was that i was anthony
reilly and i was
saying that i thought i was a [ __ ]
honeybee i mean it was kind of like
really truly felt like that
on a set before i genuinely like i've
got myself in the moments where i'm like
well listen think that was okay and
there's a bit of truth there
definitely but whatever had happened and
i had i
got myself to a place where i convinced
that um
i was telling um you know rosemary
well jamie emily
i enjoyed every day that i got to work
with you and i
enjoyed talking with you today about
wild mountain time and life in general
uh and uh i hope we talk again soon
but for today ciao ciao